today mr speaker i'd like to update the
house on the work we're doing to tackle
variants of concern
in particular variant b1617.2
which is the variant of concern first
identified in india
so that we can protect the progress that
we've worked so hard to achieve
there's now 2 323
confirmed cases of b1617.2
in the uk 483 of these cases
have been seen in bolton and blackburn
with darwin
where it's now the dominant strain cases
there have doubled in the last week
and are rising in all age groups in
blackburn
hospitalizations are stable with eight
people currently in hospital with covid
and in bolton 19 people are now in
hospital with coronavirus
the majority of whom are eligible for a
vaccine
but haven't yet had a vaccine this shows
the new variant is not
tending to penetrate into older
vaccinated groups
and it underlines again the importance
of getting the jab
especially but not only amongst the
vulnerable age groups
madame deputy speaker mr deputy speaker
mr deputy speaker in bolton and
blackburn we've taken the approach that
worked in south london
against the south african variant we've
surged in our rapid response team
100 people so far who this weekend
visited around 35
000 people to distribute and collect
tests we've installed six new testing
units we've brought in
over 50 new vaccinators and set up two
new vaccination centers
as well as extending opening hours and
capacity at our existing sites
in bolton we've quadrupled the rate of
vaccination
we carried out 6200 vaccinations
over this weekend and it's brilliant to
see so many people
from the most vulnerable groups coming
forward to get the protection whether
it's coming forward to get the first jab
or coming forward to get their second
jab all in all
this is the biggest surge of resources
into any specific local area we've seen
during the pandemic so far it's been
coordinated by dr jenny harris the chief
executive of the new
uk health security agency drawing on all
the health capabilities locally and
nationally
that we've built in the last year i want
to thank everyone who's working so hard
to make it happen
including everyone at the two local
authorities the rapid response team
all the volunteers including from st
john's ambulance and most importantly
the people of bolton and blackburn for
the community spirit they're sharing
it's been really heartening i'm sure the
whole house will agree
to see the videos that have been
published over the weekend of people
queuing up to get the jab
and to anyone who feels hesitant not
just in bolton or blackburn
but to anyone who feels hesitant about
getting the vaccine right across the
country
just look at what's happening in bolton
hospital where the majority of people
in hospital with coronavirus were
eligible
for the jab but have chosen not yet to
have the jab
and have ended up in hospital some of
them in intensive care
vaccines save lives mr deputy speaker
they protect you they protect your loved
ones
and they will help us all get out of
this pandemic
mr deputy speaker this isn't just about
bolton and blackburn
there are now 86 local authorities where
there are five
or more confirmed cases the next biggest
case of concern is bedford where we are
surging
testing and i would urge everybody in
bedford
to exercise caution and engage in
testing
where it is available mr speaker i
deputy speaker i also want to tell the
house the latest scientific assessment
of this variant
the early evidence suggests that b1617.2
is more transmissible than the
previously dominant
b 1 7 variant we do
not yet know to what extent it's more
transmissible
and while we also don't have the
complete picture
on the impact of the vaccine the early
laboratory data from oxford university
corroborates the provisional evidence
from bolton hospital
and the initial observational data from
india
that vaccines are effective against this
variant
this of course is reassuring but the
higher transmission poses
a real risk all this supports our
overriding strategy
which is gradually and cautiously to
replace
the restrictions on freedom with the
protections
from the vaccines the data suggests that
the vaccine has already saved over 12
000 lives and prevented over 33 000
people from being hospitalized
and we're protecting people at a very
rapid pace
the last week was the biggest week of
vaccinations
since the end of march 36 million people
have now had a first dose
and yesterday we reached the milestone
of 20 million people
having had their second dose across the
uk
and i'm delighted i'm delighted to see
the figures released
by yougov today which show that the uk
has the highest vaccination enthusiasm
in the world
with 90 percent of people saying that
they have had or will have the jab
this was no accident we began planning
the campaign for vaccine uptake a year
ago
and i want to thank the huge range of
people
involved in promoting the benefits of
vaccination from
her majesty the queen to sir elton john
and henry redknapp and
lenny henry holly willoughby and lydia
west and many
many others our campaign has been based
on
positivity and science and i'm grateful
to everyone
including so many members of this house
from
all sides who have played their part
from tomorrow i can confirm that we will
be inviting people aged 37
to come forward before expanding this
further
later in the week it's been brilliant to
see the enthusiasm people have had when
they've been invited to come forward
and we want to make it as easy as
possible for people to
show that they've had the protection
that the vaccine provides and i'm
delighted to say that as of today
people can now demonstrate whether
they've had their job quickly and simply
through the nhs app mr deputy speaker
since january we've been following a
dosing interval of
12 weeks for second doses
because the extra protection you get
from a second dose
particularly amongst those most likely
to end up in hospital or
dying it is incredibly important that
everyone comes forward for that second
dose
at the right moment the approach we've
taken
aims to give the most vulnerable the
strongest possible protection against
the virus
so since january that's meant getting
the first dose to as many people as
possible as quickly as possible
the research shows that this approach
has saved around
12 000 lives now it's important to
accelerate the second doses
of all those most vulnerable to ending
up in hospital
or dying so our vaccination strategy for
all parts of the uk
including the areas of surge vaccination
will stick by the clinical advice set
out by the jcvi
first prioritize anyone over 50 who has
not yet been vaccinated
next second doses to those over 50 are
vital
which will now be done at a schedule of
eight weeks
then follow the cohorts in priority
order and the age groups as we open them
this clinically approved approach is the
best way to save the most lives
rather than jumping ahead with first
doses for younger people
while the jcvi of course keeps this
clinical advice
under constant review we are clear that
their advice
is the best way to protect those most
in need of protection and so save as
many lives as we can
the nhs will be reiterating this advice
to all vaccination centers and all
directors of public health
and i'm very very grateful to everyone
in the
nhs in local authorities and in the
whole system supporting this vaccination
program
for following it mr deputy speaker
today's
opening and step three marks an
important step on our road to recovery
we must proceed with caution and care
and bear down on the virus in whatever
form it attacks us
so that in this race between the vaccine
and the virus
it's our humanity our science and our
ingenuity
that will prevail and i commend this
statement to the house